We have a server that can say hello, so
now let's add some more
functionality to it.
Most modern websites have
more than just one page, so
let's figure out how to add
this feature to our web server.
In this section we will see that our
server can handle different types of
GET requests, and respond with
different types of messages.
Instead of replying with hello,
let's make a page that also replies in
Spanish when we visit the hola URL.
I'm going to copy my if block
from before and paste it below.
I will change the message
that said hello in English,
to hola in Spanish,
using this special entity code that
HTML will render as
an upside-down exclamation point.
I will also add an anchor tag to link
back to my original hello page, just so
we can see how that's done here.
Now, I'm ready to try and
run this and see what happens.